you have a game off stream oh all the
time oh really you're just addicted like
playing games do you think the biggest
thing that stops me from Ultra streaming
um is just my voice gets tired so I
typically stream six to eight hours
every day it's a lot of talking it's a
lot of talking so at some point like I
physically will like there's a time
where I just lost my voice and like I
was like I've just been talking too much
yeah I think it's like um that's the way
you draw the line yeah like when you
just can't and I'll still be playing the
same game off stream I just can't talk
um I feel like it's like Disneyland yeah
so do you have games that you play on
stream or games you play offstream or is
it always the same game
um usually the same actually sometimes
there's a few games I just play off
stream because like yeah
um for stream or something yeah like if
I if I can't talk while playing like if
I have to focus a lot yeah yeah I feel
bad if I'm not talking because it's like
yeah
yeah for sure it does depend on on the
game
you're more truer gamer than Connor is
man
I mean I just played TFT off stream
because no one wants to go on stream too
because no one wants to watch you play
TFT I just don't know what to talk about
I can't be like yo guys I'm rolling the
best you know like it's hard to it's
hard to like be excited and nothing
crazy crazy yeah it's also like a lot of
a lot of information uh being taken in
if you don't know it and it makes no
sense and a lot of backseating so much
backseating which makes it you know a
struggle a bit of a struggle yeah yeah
there's some games that are just awful
at back seating yeah chess is bad oh my
God I remember stress is so bad you know
like reduced by 200 messages so it's 200
points just by streaming it unironically
uh I believe I was 100 ELO chess player
because I was well first of all I only
did the bong Cloud because I thought it
was funny
throw that in with the fact I'm actually
just bad at the game and it was an
absolute disaster
um Conor's pretty good I know it's gone
because I've lost okay yeah he lost the
gone yeah like once or I mean
it's a shame I try not to relive but
it's okay he uh won it uh the chess
boxing I did be loving that was fun
laughing were you ready for that you
looked kind of surprised uh well I
didn't know until like three hours
before Oh I always slapped you oh you
maybe thought he wasn't gonna like
actually no no I I don't know I think I
knew it was gonna happen I just I guess
you you don't know how can you prepare
for slap if you were hitting him first
would you have gone easy uh uh I don't
know like I definitely would have if I
was if I was there and I was against my
friend I'd be like no we're not doing
this for real right guys I'd be like oh
there you go and then I feel like we
think the same on a lot of things so I
kind of just knew telepathically with
him I was like all right I know how hard
we're going
um very hard it wasn't that hard I think
I have a video that is out right now
where I got slapped by muscle girls and
they definitely went way harder probably
buffer than Ludwig I bet um most
certainly buffer than London there's
like a muscle girl yeah is that one yeah
yeah 18 of them beat me up you got what
would they just line up 18 of them just
walk yeah 18 of them yeah yeah she's got
a dog piles I did how did you come
across this like did you just walked in
you're like excuse me could you all slap
me like oh you can pay for that normally
yeah pay them to sleep all I did is an
interesting place some guys are into
that yeah well that's a lot of the
customers that go they love being
slapped yeah there's so many weird bars
here that you can pay for which would
you like to be slapped by a muscle girl
or is that not really your thing
probably not I mean you should try
you pay for money for it right it feels
like I've done something wrong if I got
slapped normally but if I pay money it's
like it's transaction I did not pay
money for it though
so it felt good because it's free still
though it was I was like I'm getting a
steal and I'm getting content but the
slapping part was the worst part of the
whole transaction cost like is it like
10 bucks a slash I think it was 30 bucks
30 bucks for a slap I think it was 18 of
them yeah I just gave you like 600
smackers yeah yeah damn well nearly let
me just stop yeah yeah that's that's a
large value for money that's what I
that's what I thought when I was getting
beaten up I was like this is great value
dying on the floor you're like yo I'm
getting my money's this is straight it's
got like 600 bucks I can't say I don't
like a deal though better than the
designer clothing yeah it's just like
actually I don't get paid in money
anymore uh just uh pay me in slaps
that's that's my currency there was like
a part of me for a brief second that got
it until I got slapped a second time and
I was like don't get it anymore and I
was like this is just but for the first
slap I was like I see I see what this is
yeah
I kind of got the appeal of you just a
woman just hitting you I was like I was
like I kind of got it for a brief second
until it actually started hurting and I
was like no more no more of this stuff
stop yeah yeah you guys also enjoy the
slapping no I'm good
I definitely have a little bit of
masochistic traits there's part of me
that does like get it like a little you
know when you get everyone does secretly
yeah just not he's like no he's not yeah
it's at different levels right yeah yeah
you wanna you wanna try a little bit no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no I don't want to I don't wanna no
no I can't Jay will do it wait actually
it's a hate crime if I do it he can do
it
I don't know three guys here I know
you're the best
I have rings on so I'm gonna hurt him
take the Rings off oh my God okay you
don't slowly take them off I don't want
to slap you well it's not hard you're
not I can't hold back it's not possible
I'm competitive
Ken party from Bleach
I'd slap you full pound go if that was
only ten percent
yeah yeah I pronounce things wrong on
purpose okay okay yeah yeah I know but
uh yeah there's a lot of weird Services
you can get here in Japan
um I don't get the slap taken in them
outside so he's got it outside he has a
wife which one did you enjoy the most of
the weird none of them none of them
which one like did you dislike the least
like oh that's good at least you know if
you had to do one right again and you're
like I'm gonna not hate this one dislike
the leash okay so there's two
um out of everything my wife has uh
forced me to do this this is gonna sound
so bad right because okay either either
option is bad but the one I dislike the
least out of everything she's forced me
to do is probably getting whipped that
is do you like the pain because the pain
is not bad you know what because okay
okay here's here's what I have a weird
question did your wife do it to you or
did your she make someone else do it she
made someone else do it to me that's
crazy
okay
watch yeah she was uh she was that so
like
yeah we went to this bar okay uh and I
was like my wife covers a lot of like
weird bars so she was I pick a bar that
we're going to film a video in together
yeah so so yeah
what I thought was the most
family-friendly sounding bar it was a
steampunk bar I was like Grace steampunk
I love steampunk I've seen Arcane you
know if I'm famous with their whipping
yeah Alchemist I was like what's the
worst thing that could happen at this
bar and uh so there were a few like
punishment uh punishment games that you
could pay for at this bar and I I
thought they were just going to be a
very very strong drink or something so
the first punishment was labeled milk
right so I was like oh it's just it's
just gonna be like uh like a gallon of
milk challenge you drink yeah yeah it's
just gonna be like uh like they Spike
some milk with alcohol or something uh
yeah I thought it was gonna be it does
sound kind of gross yeah yeah but it was
like a punishment that I was like okay I
I I'll do it for the content it was an
alcoholic milk uh what was it so the
first thing they did was
um they get they go to the back room and
the first thing they emerge out with is
um is a bib and a baby bottle
and I'm like where is this going right
now okay and uh so they get you to uh go
on your knees and they put the bib on
you and they hit you and then you have
to make baby noises
your wife made you go to bed
and then they uh feed you through the
baby bottle and uh that was one of the
most embarrassing experiences
honestly between that and getting
whipped I'd I'd pick I'd get whipped too
yeah that just sounds absolutely great
oh my God the craziest thing is your
wife wanted you to do this yeah my uh
she paid for it yeah she paid for it my
wife paid for it yeah um well you know
just watched you do it did she get a
kick out I mean I mean okay so when she
she did a punishment uh as well which
was wasn't as bad as mine it was like
they I I feel like she knew what she was
doing she was like you can get the milk
one that sounds like uh that sounds like
the team yeah that doesn't sound too big
yeah meanwhile she was like she got a
fake interrogation with uh and then you
know she was she was in like a fake
interrogation and the bomb but the bar
Maids were like faking like a really
really harsh interrogation and then they
had like a syringe full of alcohol that
which they like you know kind of like
forced her to drink that was that was
easy that almost sounds like exciting
yeah exactly yeah exactly compared to
the strange the strange baby bottle with
the whipping and the the noises yeah
yeah that's that's it that's what you
can look forward to and yeah next time
you're in Japan yeah so if you were to
recommend me a strange experience it'd
be the whipping okay honestly honestly
whatever you're into whatever you're
into I don't think I'm into anything but
like I don't know I just you don't know
until you try yeah if you have the
purest mind and we could really just
taint that so yeah just yeah go to the
muscle building
uh
uh no no I haven't I've I uh I walked in
a strip club here for a while you worked
in it well for like an hour or two you
stripped it uh yeah not very well I
think I didn't make a lot of money oh my
God it's on YouTube you can watch it
it's is that it's allowed on YouTube a
lot of it isn't so I blurred a lot of it
yeah okay yeah it's uh they were nice it
was good fun time wow okay all right now
tell me your crazy story um he's dressed
up as a baby gotten whipped uh he's been
a stripper have you have you seen violet
evergarden yeah um no but the music's
amazing in that yeah you know about it
though right yeah I know the job so I
watched uh a porn star dressed up as
Violet from Violet evergarden get DP'd
and I and I put it on YouTube
what like in live no it's not on the
video no it's not all no I mean like you
were there in the room I was there I
made eye contact with her that is so
strange yeah that's a thing
you just what you just paid money and
just walked in no I got it for free
no no no no no no no no no no no so I
did it I did like a a behind the scenes
of a porn with your followers though if
you want to it should be fine yeah sure
no I was just shocked that that's a
thing
obviously yeah well yeah but I mean like
I just you just turned up so I heard
you're doing my question for you is
where did you did you come up with this
idea you talk to your team and you're
like guys I really want to see this
happen no no
we have a we have a mutual friend uh who
used to be a Japanese porn star and She
Got Me The Roots yeah
and she was like are you interested I
was more wondering if it was your idea
I'm gonna go look for it I'm getting my
team on it they're gonna find it let's
see where they're filming this right now
ever Gardens my favorite
[Laughter]
that it no longer became my favorite
show yeah I can imagine yeah I I you
guys are crazy
once you realize as soon as you get in
contact with one of these bars or one of
these like weird places a lot of them
know each other so a lot of them will
recommend you to go to other places well
because they're really really well
connected so you want to make a good
impression because if you can make a
good impression with one that just kind
of opens the door for literally anything
this this country is just a treasure
Trove of content yeah
very sorry for tainting your innocent
mind I feel very very bad right now I
mean I'll probably never see this stuff
I guess yeah unless you want us yeah I
mean I don't even think I'd be able to
find it if I well I haven't even been
able to get around for the most part I
I've always been like hey can you help
me get around like when I came here
um I got march to just be I was like
March call the call the thing and I'll
just get in and they'll drop me off
right he's like yeah I can do that and I
was like okay gotten lost on the train
system a couple times yep
um
yeah that's the whole thing and I
haven't gotten on it you'll be a pro
next it goes the opposite direction yet
yeah so that I have that's good I still
do that yeah a lot of times I have gone
to like the wrong Tunnel right right if
that makes sense yeah sometimes yeah
that can happen yeah